from Sports Illustrated MLB networking
Fox Tom Verducci how are you Tom
good it's strange days indeed right a
month from spring training and there are
three managerial opening I mean it is
wild and the belt Ron
I guess resignation does that surprise
you at all Tom not really it was
probably in the cards once the report
came out in which he was identified not
just as part of the 17 Astros 9 stealing
scheme but a major part of it not just
an active participant but in some ways a
mastermind of it it was on on his idea
that actually their science dealing with
a runner on second base went full
throttle with the trash can from
basically every pitch and you know
listen I know the Mets hired him before
it first became public that the Astros
were going to be under investigation but
think about this Carlos Beltran needed
to explain what was in that report at
some point as a New York Mets manager
and once you do that I mean you don't
come out of that looking very good right
because you're on the record right now
as being a cheater and then you also
lied about because II did lie to the
media when he was specifically asked
about that while he was a candidate and
you know I just don't know how you undo
those two things you've never managed
before and you're starting your term as
the Mets manager with this huge issue
that you cheated
stealing signed and then you lied about
it to the media I don't know if he lied
about it to the Mets front office but
the fact is publicly he's on record as
saying oh no we didn't have a camera we
weren't doing anything like that that's
a tough way to begin your job especially
in New York as a major league manager
well yeah I mean the fact that out of
all the players that get one gets
mentioned from a Commissioner's Office
and it's Beltran which to me was a
bright shining neon sign from the
Commissioner's Office to the Wilpon
family into the Mets organization do
something is what that read to me yeah
also you have to remember he was
identified in the Athletics reporting on
the scandal as a player who was at least
at the core of what was going on we
didn't know exactly
the ramifications or at least the
specifics of that but he was named in
previous reporting so I think because
that because of that that he was
mentioned the fact that it was such a
prominent role that's why the
Commissioner laid it out there by the
way that's before that nine page report
I mean I I'm in telling people that is
extremely transparent I don't think
anybody reads that report and thinks
well why did the Commissioner do what he
did or what really happened there I mean
they list it all out there in great
detail well the two parts about that
report that I'd love to talk with you
about here number one that hinge was
portrayed by the Commissioner as being a
reluctant I guess observer of all of
this and destroyed two pieces of
equipment to express his displeasure
with what was going on and his own
organization that he could have stopped
with just one wave of the hand why
didn't that happen you know
Hinch what what what happened with him
Tom yeah it's a great point I mean first
of all I think you have to separate the
fact that you know the memo from the
Commissioner about essentially this is
now illegal and subject to penalties
that memo went out in September of 17
right the Astra's started doing this at
least in the report early in the 17th
season and actually at the work team is
doing this going back to 14 to 15 but
that's another story but anyway that's
the warning in September so at that
point you are obligated at that point
knowing that seams facing harsh
penalties before you you might think
nobody's watching and other teams are
doing it but at that point you have to
shut it down why he didn't do it at that
point well first of all the memo that
went out there just luneau got and did
not circulate it among the team and did
not walk downstairs to the manager and
coaches and say we better be in
compliance of this that alone is a
fireable offense and the report does say
that if luneau had done either one of
those things we would not be here today
and that's not giving AJ Hinch of past
by no means he needed to really gather
his team together and say knock it off
and he didn't do that why I think just
clubhouse culture and what that's like
to be down there you have a core group
of guys a lot of veteran players you
have a coach and Alex core and a key
player and Carlos
Beltran who are at the center of this
thing you're upsetting your clubhouse
culture now that needed to be done don't
get me wrong mmm I'm just telling you
that as a manager you kind of caught
between here between let's face it job
one of being a big league manager today
is what is having confidence in your
players getting your players to trust
you and to connect with them
GM's use that term all the time about
what they want in a manager well now you
got to go against that be an old-school
bad boy you know Dallas green type of
manager and tell him knock it off and he
didn't do that that's his fault
I'm but no way am i excusing him but you
have to understand the environment down
there in real time is a lot more
complicated than it might think well
that's why I asked you of to get that
sort of perspective and I want to put a
pin in clubhouse culture for a second
and get to the second aspect of the
commissioners nine page report that
leaves a question to me it just said it
was used in the 2017 postseason and did
not and did not at all detail that and I
want to know I'm already seeing videos
on Twitter right now of whistling that's
happening during Kershaw getting lit up
and Game four of a series that there was
no whistling while they were having
trouble trying to figure him out they
were up for nothing I mean I'm seeing
this stuff and I just as a fan it makes
me so irate Tom and I don't even have a
care about the Dodgers so I'm asking you
what what did happen in that postseason
what - what effect was all this used
well it's a great question we'll never
know the answer to that but the fact
that that question exists puts
everything under suspicion right you can
pick out a pitch that Kerr saw it
through and he had a four to nothing
lead and and gave up six runs and was on
the verge of putting them one win away
from winning the World Series and he'd
be a postseason hero and his whole
narrative would be different
was it one pitch was it many pitches
where there's no pitches we don't know
but the fact that the Commissioner
outlined it as you said very
specifically throughout the 2017
postseason the Astros were cheating it
puts it all under the category of
suspicion now I don't think that the
trashcans system was used in the 2017
postseason I think that would be too
difficult simply because
the postseason it's the only games going
on right there's so much more scrutiny
at that point I don't think you can get
away with it like you can for a mid
series and midweek series in July or
August but clearly with something going
on they were misusing technology to
decode signs to what extent we don't
know but again it puts their entire
championship to me under scrutiny and
questioning and the fan has every right
to say that it's painted because the
commissioner essentially did the same
thing Tom Verducci here on the Rich
Eisen show MLB Network Fox Sports
Illustrated amidst all of this craziness
let's get to the clubhouse culture we're
already hearing from Jessica Mendoza who
I respect immensely I truly enjoy her
work on ESPN talking about how Mike
fiers broken omerta code essentially is
when I'm paraphrasing she said that
today fires is beginning to guess
getting some heat for talking to the
athletic is he in some sort of code
violation that can affect his playing
career and his ability to be a teammate
Tom do you think no I don't think so I
was if he's in trouble because he's a
truth-teller there's something wrong
with this world you know it isn't only
agenda and I truly believe this is he
wants a clean game
I don't know how you hold that against
anybody you know it reminds me of when I
wrote the story about steroids and
baseball and talked to Ken Caminiti in
2002 and on the record he was the first
guy to basically say the emperor had no
clothes this has been going on and I
have nothing to hide and there were
people would call the Miss niche but you
know what the game is better off for
knowing that instead of a living with a
very dirty game that was all kept under
the covers I have no problem with what
Mike fiers did with him the guy pitched
more innings than anybody on the 2017
Astros he was left off the postseason
roster maybe he had some hard feelings I
don't know but I do know that as a
member of the Tigers and then the a is
the next couple of years he told his
teammates be careful in Houston man
these guys can pick up signs in legal
and illegal ways like nobody else and he
wanted to stop it I have no problem with
a guy who pitches agenda is to clean up
the game I'm all for that we have a
better game when we let the players
decide the outcome of the games and not
technology well and then
that leads me again to how the current
Astros are gonna be viewed by players
around the league CC Sabathia has been
very vocal he's pissed he thinks he's
got he had a title stolen from him
how will the the Astros who said let's
Bank let's bang the Macan and and and
anybody in any locker room knows
certainly when you're in a championship
team you'll look around when you're
maybe spraying champagne and your
teammates you all know every
championship team knows any player in
college knows that the championship team
you're looking at in the locker room is
gonna change people are gonna disperse
and wind up in different spots huh did
they not care that people would around
the league know that they're cheaters
based on other players talking I mean
how will the Astros be viewed in all of
this do you think well I'm glad you
asked that question because when you
think about CC Sabathia or David Freese
or Trevor Plouffe or Phil Hughes or some
of these other players who come out and
said some things about the Astros I'm
not talking about hinge or crane or Luna
the Astros players what's the common
denominator they're all out of the game
you tell me where is the noise from
current players complaining about what
the Astros were proven to do with the 20
17 and 18 seasons there is radio silence
and you know the answer to why that's
the case rich because because with a
very common thing right in 2017 that's
why I mean I'm still waiting for
somebody to complain that a you know
someone an active player to say the
Astros did something that nobody else
was doing you're not going to hear that
and I'm no way am i excusing what the
Astros did because they continue to do
it after they were warned in September
of seventeen and March of 18 but the
fact is in 1516 and before September
15th of 17 this was common in baseball
this was the result of putting a
challenge based replay system in place
we're live feeds the camera focused on
home plate was put within walking
distance of the dugout that was
Pandora's Box it opened up and then the
Commissioner tried to shut it
so is it shut now
it is to that degree I mean it's sort of
you know again I just err oeid parallel
is just too easy not to go to because
you know I couldn't tell you today that
nobody uses peds but I can't tell you
with a lot harder it's the same case
with misusing technology we now have
cameras that are not dedicated on the on
home plate a team cannot put any cameras
between the valve holes other than the
network cameras and the monitor is now
in the clubhouse and on the replay on
eight second delay so you can't get
real-time video to steal signs from so
it's a lot harder that actually began in
terms of monitoring the televisions in
the 18 postseason I don't think the S or
the Red Sox were able to do the 18
postseason what the Astros did in the 17
postseason are their work around them
you know athletes when there's money at
stake and competition is at stake and we
keep scored you're looking for an edge
you'll find ways but you can't do it the
way you did in 17 for sure well that the
Alex Cora comments that started making I
guess a reemergence yesterday last
couple days from the London series in in
last June where the Yankees lit up the
Red Sox and in response to about his
pitching staff he mentions Beltran's
name and winks at somebody and says that
Beltran he knows how you know how he
works and talking about details and the
Yankees are better at details this year
than before I mean all of that makes it
seem like he thought that there was
something up even last year so that
might give you an answer to the question
of whether this is put away whether it's
appropriate to say that or not people
think there's still a way to do this
clearly right well listen there there's
different ways of doing that for
instance a team can have cameras trained
on pitchers from every angle the
ballpark to see if they're giving away
their pitches with the way they take the
ball out of their glove with the way
they span their glove or not that kind
of slough thing goes on that's a guess
legal it's not unethical there's always
gonna be ways and Beltre on besides what
he did against
rulz was always thought of as a guy who
is very good at seeing what pitchers are
doing where they might be giving away
their pitches that's part of the game we
understand that but this is why rich I'm
a big fan playing I call it American
Legion baseball turn off all the
technology once the game starts that's
the answer to this right you don't need
as a hitter to go back you know after
you're a bat and go look at every pitch
because when you do that you can see
from a centerfield shot for instance
what signs are being used right even if
your purpose was to go back there look
at something mechanically in your swing
you can still look at video in the
course of a game that's being played at
that time it's not real time but you can
use it and gain knowledge going forward
like what the wrong signs are with the
run around second base the next time
you're on second base you know that why
is that allowed why aren't people
leaving the dugout to go back and use
technology to play the game of baseball
you know I always say this it's like the
SATs you can study all you want you can
hire a tutor you can look up everything
online but when you go in there to take
the test essentially to play the game
you don't bring the laptop in you don't
bring your tutor in it's you against me
and what you know and that's what
baseball should be so I'm a big fan of
saying you want to replay monitor it's
fine put it upstairs in the press box
have one there where both teams can have
someone monitor that whether they want a
challenge or not but after that the
video room is locked everything's off
first pitch go play the game like you're
back in American Legion I love that
great point although the cynic and me
being a Los Angeles resident says you
can cheat on the si si si T to Tom we're
here in Los Angeles everything that's
been going around here last last year so
last one last one for you are we out of
shoes to drop is that it
Beltran out is that the last shoe to
drop or we're gonna learn who the
Houston Astros players are eventually
how does this continue to potentially
ripple in your mind well we still have
to find out the results of the
investigations the Red Sox won 18 right
I think that won't take as long one take
the three months the Houston one did I
I'm thinking about a month so right
around start of spring training you're
going to have a severe penalty
for Alex Cora I'm not sure if he's ever
going to manage again you can probably
gonna get another huge sign to the club
by the way the fine for the club like
the Esso is gonna find five million
dollars that's the maximum allowed under
Major League Baseball's Constitution
that has to change
you know Robinson Cano can use peds and
get suspended and lose 12 million
dollars but an entire franchise can't be
fined more than five million dollars
Betty to be updated so the Red Sox will
gets fined we'll see if any of their
front office personnel are subject to
discipline here as well because remember
they're repeat offenders they use the
Apple watch in 17 I'm assuming they'll
find something out of the 18 season so
that's next one and I don't even know if
it's gonna be last one because you know
who knows what else surfaces here the
commissioner says if you've got
information about teams stealing signs
after September 15th of 2017 bring it to
me and I'll investigate it so it's quite
possible there's others later but this
is what we have now and then of course
the managers who take these jobs what a
huge role for them not only to obviously
try and put pieces back together for
franchises that have been if you will
blown up by all of this but also for for
the integrity of the game for fans for
us to believe that these managers that
are walking in there I mean it's a huge
jobs Tom what do you think that's a
great point rich because he's hiring a
manager for these three teams now is
bigger than just you know how you run a
game it's about integrity and
re-establishing that and that's going to
take time but you better put the right
people in place and you're talking about
three really good teams right the Mets
the Red Sox and the Astros are all teams
with designs on the postseason these are
not rebuilding programs so it's win now
and restore integrity I like the fact
that Euston to talk with John Gibbons
I think he's been a very underrated
manager he's a straight of a shooter as
there is players absolutely love him I
think he's great at running bullpens
which is a big part of the game today I
think he'd be a great fit in Houston I
like Eduardo Perez and either New York
or or Boston
I mean the Mets obviously liked him he's
one of the finalists and in their
discussions handling any new ones as
well their bench coach down I think
might figure in there
Red Sox could go run brenneke he's you
know obviously been there for the last
couple of years as their bench coach and
it's more of a seamless transition but
they have a new general manager he may
want to take his own guy somebody that
he's familiar with but yeah is this
again for three months away from one
month away from spring training and
three teams don't know who the manager
is and it's a very important hire and
each and every case Tom you the man love
our chats always really appreciate it I
know you're really busy amidst all this
so thanks for the call my pleasure it's
like you you bet right back at you Tom
Verducci for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app